[Music]
dude what is with the easy buttons I
thought you're gonna get like the
receptionist spells so we could do the
dings like from the sense videos I
looked man I don't know where to find
those things I don't know what store
sells those we can't debate movies and
keep score using an easy button that's
beyond lame people would think we're
stupid well this is the best I could do
all right so do you want to do it or do
you want to complain about it okay okay
what's talking about The Hobbit okay
let's talk about the Hobbit Hobbit sucks
why does the Hobbit suck The Hobbit
sucks because of all the goofy goofy the
snot the body noises that wacky brown
wizard this movie is silly as okay I
will grant you that there are some
moments of the movie that are a little
bit silly that was easy
point for me okay my turn
The Golem scene let's hear you say
something bad about the Golem scene even
an idiot like you has to has to know how
awesome that seamless let's hear you say
it was bad I want to hear it come on
come on I can't argue that exactly thank
you you happy now all right yeah my turn
I'm happy now the dishes solve the
dishes song is in the book no no no no
movie that takes a tiny-ass book and
splits it out into three movies and
fills it with all kinds of filler that
wasn't actually there that movie doesn't
get to claim it was in the book when I
criticized that movie has left the book
behind a long time ago another problem
with the dishes song is this I cannot
believe that didn't break exactly
there's no way those doors could have
done that without breaking all the
dishes that was easy
it's dwarves not doors not even a point
about the movie I don't care I score a
point every time you're a moron now
let's talk about the action cuz it was
off no it isn't the action is
kid-friendly it's stupid it's like a
dumbed down version of what middle-earth
that should not be and that's stupid you
score a point without any debate yes I
can no you can't and I just did but what
are you gonna do about it I guess I'm
gonna sit here alright well the problem
is the Blut the one the bloat the bloat
this movie has so much unnecessary
this movie has so many unnecessary
characters it's ridiculous to prove my
point I brought somebody else to help us
to discuss the boss somebody else geez
dude you know I freaking hate this guy
why do you have to bring this guy we
don't need him to debate movies he
doesn't add anything exactly tell me
this isn't exactly how you felt when
Frodo showed up and did nothing tell me
Elrond and Galadriel the Masters of
boredom have a 15-minute conference with
Gandalf tell me this isn't exactly how
you felt when the mother shows up on a
sled drawn by rabbits if I agree with
you you don't go dissin all right the
rabbits are stupid the rabbits are dumb
that was easy
all right so get rid of him he's not
that bad really
he's a little slow but we made a deal
sure it's friendly we made a deal you
said you were gonna get rid of it we did
we did but have you ever tried getting
rid of the sky like next to impossible
well then why did you even invite him
over in the first place can you at least
tell him to stop staring at me like hey
you're bothering him
[Music]